bonjour nicolas
bonjour à vous de bon ravi de vous avoir
dans cette matinale comment avez vous
perçu vous l'allocution d'emmanuel
macron mardi
mamadi libyen lorsque j'écoute emmanuel
macron je me dis que nous petits
français moyen on ne se rend pas compte
à quel point ce chef de l'état et les
solaires nous ne mesurons pas la chance
que nous avons de n'avoir réalisé tout
est si beau si simple si magique avec un
tel président il est à lui c'est une
parenthèse enchantée de l'histoire notre
pays avec ceux ci grand soleil qui nous
réchauffe le coeur car le petit père de
la populace et autres laissez passer
pour continuer à vivre dans cette
fabuleuse dystopie qui ne demande qu'à
nous manger tout cru plus besoin de
réfléchir et de s'inquiéter pour nous
notre avenir rail s'occupe de tout pour
nous et ce mardi soir cette nouvelle
réunion zoom organisé par le golden boy
de la starten d'etion a été un vrai bol
d'air frais pour les français et même si
emmanuel m'apprend avait c'est étrange
voix de lendemains de soirées très
arrosées au pit shopping go cela nous a
permis de nous rendre compte donc quel
pays formidable nous vivions sans avoir
à reconnaissant dû vendre vide de le
reconnaître magali alors nicolas on sent
poindre un peu d'ironie tout de même
chez vous le chef de l'état en at il
trop fait le moins qu on puisse dire
c'est qu'à manuel macoine hormis une
grosse couche sur la crise sanitaire
grosso modo la vaccination c'est la
liberté est vacciné vous pour vivre
normalement pour tous les petits malins
complotistes qui ne veulent pas le
comprendre c'est la peine nasale du
coton tige dans le nez jusqu'à la saint
glinglin et cela englobe bien sûr
quelques six millions de français non
vaccinés qui sont encore et toujours de
dangereuse irresponsable
de plus at il eu dans cette logorrhée
verbale de 25 minutes c'est loin
plusieurs commentateurs ont oublié de
mettre en exergue la prolongation des
gestes-barrières il y en écoutant bien
j'ai cru comprendre que tant que la
grippe la gastro ou le rhume des foins
ne serez pas éradiquée de la surface de
la terre on allait se coltiner le masque
là aussi jusqu'à la saint glinglin et
pour finir sur le thème du comics disney
peut- e pas sanitaire sera un peu comme
le pass navigo pour les parisiens il va
falloir leur charge et qu'une troisième
noce pour les plus de 65 ans et dès
demain et pour tout le monde après
demain alors moi je vous dis que cette
histoire va finir par des castes canaux
pour des abonnements chez pfizer au pied
de votre sapin de noël avait la tête
d'olivier ferrand sur les emballages ça
promet une belle jen de noël masqué
cuite dans sa sauce de gel
hydroalcoolique
emmanuel macron plus sérieusement a
aussi abordé les questions politiques il
s'est félicité notamment de la bonne
situation du pays qu'en avez-vous retenu
et bien sûr et marron qu'on ne vit pas
dans le même pays avec emmanuel macron
or le chômage ça va carrément mieux les
infirmières avaient elles sont mieux
payés sarr localité du côté des
entreprises la dette on gère des
centaines de milliers d'emplois sont à
pourvoir d'ailleurs à force ils vont
finir par devoir cloner les français au
ministère du travail pour occuper tous
ces jobs non pourvus et ils finiront en
force à parfaire mais pôle emploi parce
qu'il y aura plus rien à faire donc tout
va bien madame la marquise prolétaires
de france et en plus c'est en plus
emmanuel macron s'est découvert une
passion pour la notion de collectif
plusieurs fois dans son discours il a
insisté sur le fait que c'est
collectivement que c'est grâce à nous
tous que chacun fait sa part et c'est
donc pour cela bien que la france va
mieux mais si la notion du collectif
pour emmanuel macron c'est lé conseil de
défense ak dans un bunker atomique pour
dessiner l'avenir du pays la répression
inadmissible des contestations
populaires ou le piétinement du
parlement depuis de longs mois assure
magali que les français adhèrent à cette
convergence des idées et puis lorsque
emmanuel macron employer le mot de
démocratie ça donne envie de saigner des
oreilles après le petit père de la
populace attiré lui à boulet rouge sur
les chômeurs qui sont pour beaucoup elle
est victime expiatoire de la
mondialisation malheureuse et des
licenciements massifs suite aux
délocalisations en somme si les chômeurs
ne cherche pas du boulot sérieusement
les allocations chômage c'est terminé
ils devront tout accepter pour continuer
à gamme et les iaa be leurs enfants par
contre cette situation très
inconfortable pour beaucoup ne risque
pas d'arriver à muriel pénicaud car
l'ancien ministre du travail qui tentent
en ce moment de se recycler au poste de
directrice générale du bureau
international du travail c'est beau pour
certains la reconversion professionnelle
et selon ou alors emmanuel macron a
profité pour faire un discours de
campagne hier soir
bah oui carrément évaluer le premier
s'est offert 30 kg mardi soir sous
couvert de crise sanitaire le petit
discours de campagne fait maison est
financée par nos impôts alors on espère
que la commission nationale des comptes
de campagne or à la sagacité suffisante
pour décompter tout selon tout cela du
temps du discours très du trait certains
candidats n'a kron dans quelques
semaines sans oublier que le dernier
débat contradictoire des manuels macron
chers amis fil face à l'astrologue
thomas pesquet depuis sa station
spatiale c'est pour dire alors oui
emmanuel macron utilisé comme alibi le
coc u19 pour faire sa petite réclame
électorale en décrivant un monde de
colby seul peut voir et qu'il est le
seul à comprendre et comme le disait
sacha guitry je cite il n'y a pas de
gens modestes il ya des ratés qui ont la
prétention d'être modeste et qui font
les modestes pour faire croire qu'ils ne
sont pas des ratés
merci beaucoup nicolas et vidal faudra
que vous donniez quand même l'adresse du
pit shopping gaulle c'est bien ça fait
plaisir avec plaisir merci c'était
l'édito de nicolas vidal dans la
matinale ce matin